well of course the devil is in the
detail
but I very much hope that we will see
increased investment as a result of this
deal and we'll also see Tata Steel
honoring its commitments that it's
already made as part of the package
around the the pensions changes you know
there was a commitment from Tata Steel
for a billion pounds of investment for
guaranteeing the blast furnaces for five
years and also no compulsory early
redundancy so that that those deal those
deals those commitments have to be
honored they ring-fenced this new joint
venture does bring I think some quite
strong and positive opportunities just
through the scale and the synergies and
also really worth remembering that the
Port Talbot works have been through a
very painful and tough restructuring so
the works are as lean and as fighting
fit as you could possibly be going into
this new partnership I personally
believe that the Port Albert works is as
lean as it can be they you know the work
force has been incredible they they've
dug deep and they're turning the
business around and some of that has
been through some cost-cutting exercises
it's already cut to the bone will be
really important now to see the
opportunities for building on what we've
got and a really important part of that
will be the realigning of blast furnace
number five with Scunthorpe portal but
is the last bastion of primary
steelmaking in the UK that's where we
have the blast furnaces where you're
making steel from scratch and we need to
see now this access to more investment
more capital investment that'll come my
hope through the joint venture being
plowed into the realigning of blast
furnace number five and certainly will
be seeking assurances from thyssen krupp
and Tata Steel that that is going to be
part of the deal yes as you mentioned in
Tata Steel did make that commitment at
the time that they struck the agreement
over the pension fund but will that
pledge still be legally valid in the
event of this transaction yes I think
the three pledges that were made
as part of the pensions package are
absolutely still legally binding I think
they need to be ring-fenced you know
sealed off from this joint venture deal
what I want to see with this joint
venture deal is a commitment to
realigning blast furnace number five
because the empty the the Tata Steel
commitment around pensions was a
commitment to the blast furnaces for
five years it didn't include a
commitment to realigning a realigning a
blast furnace number five would secure
the future of the blast furnace for at
least twenty years and that's what we
want to see because with that sort of
solid base then all sorts of other
investment will flow in the markets
we'll see that there's a very serious
commitment to primary steelmaking input
Albert and I think that would be a game
changer for the future of the British
steel industry said that it's easier to
layoff workers in the UK than it is in
the Netherlands and Germany are you
going to be seeking talks with company
management to gain reassurances that
that isn't going to be the case in this
situation well again one of the really
important elements of the deal that was
struck back in February between Tata
Steel UK and the unions was that there
would be no compulsory early
redundancies and that in the case of any
potential merger or changes in the
business the British workforce would
have precisely the same rights and
protections as their your continental
European counterparts and that deal is
sacrosanct that deal is you know
ring-fenced and it must be honored those
commitments must be honored by Tata
Steel going forward so I think I'm
reasonably confident there that the
issue of compulsory or early
redundancies in the UK won't arise
because Tata Steel has made a commitment
let's not forget that the quid pro quo
was that the the workforce voted for
those changes to their pension schemes
they stepped up to the plate they showed
once again their professionalism their
commitment their dedication to the
future of the works they're thinking
about the future General
patience their their sons and grandsons
that they want to be working in in the
steelworks here and and that was a very
responsible decision that they took and
the quid pro quo for that has to be that
the management also keeps its side of
the bargain